on Earth Day 2019 Google posted this
video about the urgency of radically
addressing climate change in the next
decade this is Kate Brandt
she used to be Obama's chief
sustainability officer and now she works
to make Google a global leader juicy or
even eliminating our dependence on raw
materials and fossil fuels Google's
growing data centers need more energy
every year in 2012 just 34 percent of
that power came from renewables but by
2017 they got that up to a hundred
percent they've also managed to lower
their total energy use with some help
from a branch of artificial intelligence
called machine learning a computer
program takes in lots of data and trains
itself to operate the center's as
efficiently as possible
here's energy use under human
supervision and when the AI is in charge
the more data the AI trains on the
better it gets at reducing energy use
but here's the thing this same
technology can be used to automate lots
of other tasks like fossil fuel
discovery and extraction and while
Google is using AI to increase the
efficiency of its operation it's also
using it to try and get as much oil and
gas out of the ground as possible in
2018 Google hired Darryl Willis a
veteran of British Petroleum to lead its
new oil gas and energy division Willis
explained our plan is to be the partner
of choice for the energy industry
they've already signed a deal with total
one of the world's biggest oil companies
to develop AI that will streamline oil
and gas exploration and production and
Google is not alone Microsoft and Amazon
are also teaming up with the fossil fuel
industry big tech has entered the oil
business
On June 15 1957 the citizens of Tulsa
Oklahoma buried a rather odd time
capsule a brand-new plymouth belvedere
sealed inside among the commemorative
plates ashtrays t-shirts and books that
captured the spirit of the times was a
16 millimeter film lane
it showed a Martian visiting the United
States and learning that oil and
competition made the nation prospered
also included in the capsule were
gasoline and motor oil in 1957 it seemed
like a very real possibility that these
products wouldn't be around in 50 years
when the Belvedere was scheduled to be
disinterred newspapers around the
country were reporting that America's
oil production would soon fall off and
as that cartoon Martian learned
discoveries of new reserves were rare
and only one in almost a thousand makes
a major discovery oil has always been
really hard to find America's first oil
well was drilled in 1859 near a
particularly greasy Creek in
Pennsylvania it was obvious there was
oil seeping up from the ground here but
it took Edwin Drake over a year and all
his money to find a measly little pocket
of black gold still his discovery
triggered an oil boom and a Pennsylvania
paper was soon explaining that the
substance could illuminate lubricate
make candles and cure most diseases from
which humanity suffers not all of that
proved true but a hundred years later
petroleum had given the world fabrics
higher insecticide cosmetic weed killers
a whole galaxy of things to make a
better life on earth
and of course fuel the energy needs of
the world have risen a lot since 1859
and from very early on there were fears
that fossil fuels couldn't meet this
demand 1909 some thatíll and gas would
run out around 1937 in 1937 US oil
supplies were supposed to disappear by
1952 and so on and so on as fossil fuels
became more and more essential in
everyday life predictions of a crash
kept coming
but somehow the oil kept flowing I
couldn't imagine how this
ever-increasing supply of oil was
achieved until I found out that there's
not just one but thousands of oil
companies all competing with each other
to discover and develop new sources of
oil from the earliest days competing
companies invested in better technology
to extract fossil fuels better drills
better pumps and they developed better
techniques for finding new oil reserves
reading seismic vibrations to see
underneath the ground using satellite
lidar to reveal hidden structures
detecting in subtle changes in the
Earth's gravity and magnetism thanks in
part to these advances by 2007 when a
very rusty Belvedere was exhumed global
oil production was still on the rise in
the u.s. it did look like oil was
finally petering out until investment in
new technology fracking and horizontal
wells and vast shale formations brought
it roaring back today once again if we
just rely on current reserves and
current tech oil production will start
to falter but if new technology lets us
squeeze more out of the reserves we
already have and find new sources of oil
we'll be able to meet the growing demand
and it's just a matter of funding the
next technological leap
of course there's a problem with using
fossil fuels to meet the world's energy
needs
climate change oil gas and coal are a
time capsule of a different sort sealing
ancient carbon deep below the earth when
humans open that time capsule and burn
those fossil fuels carbon re-enters the
atmosphere as the greenhouse gas co2
since 1859 co2 levels have shot up and
so has the planet's temperature if we
keep going like this if we burn all the
fossil fuels we currently have access to
models suggest that the earth can warm
somewhere between six point four and
nine point five degrees and so climate
activists say there's only one thing to
do that's easier chanted than done
currently the world relies on fossil
fuels for 85 percent of its energy
keeping it in the ground will require a
huge shift to renewables and lower
energy use in general and big tech
companies have publicly rushed to be
part of this effort sustainability has
been a core value since our founding
there had been pockets of sustainability
living within amazon's business since
the very beginning one of the problems
we can help solve is energy consumption
we can invent our way out of this
problem innovation is the key to solving
this problem we can put artificial
intelligence and digital technology to
use to help our customers in every part
of the economy become more sustainable
themselves it turns out that same
artificial intelligence technology is
just what oil companies need to stay
profitable leave the fossil fuel
industry has amassed lots and lots of
valuable data as they've mapped Earth's
crust in search of reserves take this
patch of ocean floor in the North Sea in
1989 Dutch geologists painstakingly
mapped the different rock layers using
seismic scans researchers at IBM
recently fed all that seismic data into
a machine learning algorithm and after
about ten minutes of training the AI was
able to label the rock layers nearly as
accurately as human experts another
group at Georgia Tech used machine
learning to quickly identify structures
important to oil discovery
you can imagine how an AI could train
itself with all kinds of data to
pinpoint the best places to drill and
once drilling begins AI can streamline
extraction to make it cheaper that kind
of efficiency can help the oil and gas
industry compete with renewables and so
it's no surprise they spent an estimated
1.75 billion dollars on AI in 2018
Google Microsoft and Amazon are
competing for a piece of that pie Google
has signed agreements with several
fossil fuel companies Microsoft has
teamed up with Exxon and Chevron and
just hired Darryl Willis away from
Google and Amazon who already provides
cloud services to BP and shell is
marketing its ability to accelerate and
optimize exploration drilling and
production of oil and gas while they
talk up their commitment to
sustainability big tech is making sure
the world can keep earning plenty of
fossil fuel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]